hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
remember the pound puppies sure you do
their marketing gimmick was far too
clever to overlook by one of our cute
said Moodle puppies or else to get the
gas mask you it was a brilliant idea and
like most toys in the 1980s if it was
popular it warranted a show so we got
the pound puppy show which was just as
Drive or ideas as the executives who
green lighted it I don't know you got
these dogs in a pound but they get dogs
out of the pound or sleep a woman who
runs it but then there's daughter who
runs if she tries to capture them even
though they're somehow already in a
pound something about magic power of L
allows them to talk to humans it wasn't
this and just to make it even more
confusing they had a theatrical release
that switched things up even more that
was pound puppies the legend of big
emotionally lagging and creatively
retarded the pound puppies movies just
as big a sellout of you with thing and
considering how it was based on a show
that was a sellout that was based on a
toy that was a sellout there's a lot of
fuckin selling out to be done here so
why should these characters have been
Korean appetizers let's take a look so
it's a beautiful day in whatever's Vil
the sun is shining the clouds are out
the car stopped in mid dissolve it's
absolutely wonderful and on this day we
see three dogs walking to the museum
Thiago Motta why are you taking it all
you said was it's a little surprise did
you like surprises on cooperative kids
wanted a cameo
whoa that could have been me thanks that
will be you if you don't start watching
the light and wait for the walk signal
before you cross why thanks magic
walking talking dog boy this is the best
high ever it's a good thing we still
have puppy power
who else I couldn't have talked to him
yes apparently there's this thing called
puppy power where dogs and humans can
magically talk to one another not to
late to get a refund folks where did it
come from anyways on coopera wait'll you
hear this it all started back in the
dark ages back in the days of the night
wait a minute what things were a lot
different that's it good and evil nights
not each other for the right to search
my dome isn't a sword Excalibur no sorry
I came in to watch pound puppies the
little dogs
unfortunately the evil Black Knight what
when did this become Spamalot the
animated series
hi I'm pussy macbeth elune britches and
i have no idea why we jumped from
talking dogs to quest for Camelot table
scraps kind of weird so the Black Knight
not wearing any black chases after the
boy and his dog know for the pleasure of
finishing you
for dry red eyes clear eyes is awesome
ah so the boy just happens to stumble
across the sword in the stone and the
moon of school what the what the moon of
school there's a bone in the stone
why would I ever put a bone in the stone
what's the point what was mama drunk
when he came up with their little tidbit
dad he who pulls the sword from the
stone
won't be named King I just thought of
something
what if they're just here Mia what if we
put a bone in the stone I don't know why
I Rose gonna be like why is our bone
it'll jog with the most important I blah
blah blah I'm gonna be like a that good
day puppy power
I was gonna be like what the hell is
puppy power
well I'll tell you in a second
our gray how to hell with this I'm
devoting my life to catching Spurs yeah
sure scared him
you can talk we can talk without power
so I guess they just equate a puppy
power on the spot and it seemed to stick
but I shall never wished him to the boon
of Scoon is may and should I feel the
Sons of the McNasty clan McNasty really
that's his name you know you're sort of
leaning his future towards evil when you
call somebody mad I can't really see a
daycare center call make nasties some
story huh kids one thing I don't
understand don't go opera yeah just try
act like you give us you will play which
brings me to another story about how we
almost lost puppy power yes because we
can't keep track of where the fuck this
movie's going we cut to yet another
flashback this one takes place in the
50s ok so we see our main characters
from the original show cooler Bright
Eyes knows Murray howler and whopper
yeah look nothing like the original
designs do they in fact nothing else is
like the original show if you grew up
with it
the owners are different the time period
is different even the personalities the
little there were are different but
he'll care they're having such a rockin
good time
let's go to
let's go towel pound looks awesome
I never knew all the full nails missing
out on all this time come on let's go
call the pal right now dance you can hug
it even better but you better not for
gen'l'men but oh it's I'm getting a term
in commemoration of a thousand year
anniversary the bonus cone will be
holding an adoption Bazaar at the pound
yeah and everybody's invited to come
over and adopt the pound puppy or pound
Peru of their choice wait a pound
hurry did you really just call a cab a
pound hurry
what did house pussy just caused too
much controversy some day one of big
paws descendants will guard the bone of
Scone again it's like my great grand
puppy said to me uh schoolers are
descended from King Arthur's puppy dig
Allah who wrote this just then a nurse
puppy comes in to let them all know the
good news it's time it's time it's time
it's time it's time it's time is it time
actually they're talking about a batch
of puppies being born which is so
overblown it's making the nativity look
phoned in
what are they look at them they're just
so cute what guy is weird
you're right whopper there's something
odd about that man yeah what did you put
no young lady at the papers please
uh-oh look out for reflux I love you
I love you yes this interesting mental
psychosis has a very strange reaction
when he hear the bell he runs around
kissing people saying that he loves them
it's the stupidest thing I've ever heard
in my life no rhyme or reason I think
this calls for another
ah move fucking pound pervert so after
having sold the puppies to a man with
razor-sharp teeth womper decides to
follow him to see what his evil plan is
after a few minutes in my machine these
gentle puppies will be transformed into
vicious guard dumps this is a metal
dilution you enter here then go through
this corridor right to the bone then I
have the power of the bone and my army
of vicious attack dogs I'll take over
the pound and then the country and then
though of course
so Wooper goes and tells everybody what
he saw but nobody believes it all right
whopper that's enough it's good that you
have an active imagination but you have
to learn to control it
really this is a movie that starts off
with Excalibur talking puppies and a guy
named McNasty I think we've established
that there's nothing far-fetched in this
movie so it's up to whopper himself to
stop the thugs from stealing the bone
this is gonna be a piece of cake
hey don't mention food I'm starving all
right hey lumpy you know how we were
talking about the other day how we're in
every single solitary movie ever the fat
guy and the skinny guy who are both
thugs yeah do you think that's a
throwback to classic character
development or just really shitty right
I pick the water so the bone is broken
in half which means that Oh puppy power
in the world is taken away
I saw whopper run what's going on I
can't understand Colette Hey I can't
understand Tammy a Jeff well that's odd
it's almost normal so through a
confusing JC we see the thugs get half
of the bone as well as whopper and that
mother dog we gotta find the bone and
put it back together if we want puppy
power back what if we can't we have to
or kids and puppies will never be able
to talk again it'll be like the way it
was in the dark ages
oh no it would be like pretty much how
it is now oh uh oh
listen it's the pup Ling's I think
they're saying my disappearing sloppily
animated noses back at the pound so what
the mother gone nobody can feed the pot
so they rip off 101 dalmations by Helen
to all the Daleks trying to get
information okay a fat guy in a skinny
guy are headed out of town on a
motorcycle wait wait I've heard this one
the punchline is pineapple right we're
gonna rescue let's get crackin thanks
but uh Tracking's a dog's job well I
thought we were all friends
boy older thought that cooler was an
anti cat tight some big nasty plans to
throw the pups into his mean machine
that turns nice dogs into bad dogs as he
sings about how evil and terribly is
control will be mine all I need is that
belt I've got a plan in mind you put me
on the throne you know doing acapella
with a man who's screaming and isn't
really singing doesn't count as a song
you need more musical accompaniment then
Dada Dada Dada there now the world will
be mine my time has finally come
in the McNasty bloodline I'm a son of a
son of a gun
oh god I never thought I would say this
but bring the rapping dog back
yeah meanwhile we kept a cooler on the
gang as they travel through the woods
bad as the dialog is at least we don't
listen to another crime yeah oh so as
they travel through hi ronin s box hell
we see the whopper and the mother
escaped and catch up with the gang but
they're captured again five minutes
later so this was completely pointless I
think that it comes off a minute we just
saw the mother get put away now she's
back with the groom was there a Stargate
in that bag was something move God gang
look nail so they have a little chase
and end up in the mineshaft where the
pups are left hanging hey fuckin up my
kin all right but luckily toll Oaks cat
is there to save the day job for a dog
huh we figured you'd need a sooner or
later I never thought I'd say this but
thanks cat you're alright oh good colors
able to put his deeply rooted cat
prejudice aside for one day
goodie goodie so McNasty puts the dogs
in the mean machine or rather a
pointless conveyor belt that they easily
could have rolled off of it's cool on
the gang find themselves in even more
trouble
hey I can't swim don't worry it's
quicksand uh no that's water
are there any sharks and quicksand it's
so obviously water it's blue it's like
when you can swim in it it's water
do you animators just have trouble
drawing noses and sand what's wrong with
you
Monty Python's a flame
actually it's big part yes he's in this
movie too I'm just a lonely puppy
without a home and without any friends
but does he have a pointless song to
sing big big big big big big big big big
big big big big you know what I can use
right now I could use a shot of Tyler
Durden penis I don't usually say that
but this just seems like the perfect
movie to put it so when the snooty cat
and the courageous dog with the
celebrity voices meet for the first time
in real 3 that's when you'll catch a
flash of Tyler's nose that they saw it
Hey nice so the pound puppies and their
new friend big Paul approach the lair of
our villain I'd better hide but you
better hide your giant why don't you try
eating the fucking house so the rest of
them get caught and are about to be
turned into evil puppies but it turns
out McNasty wants the cats to leave
because he's allergic his key is cooler
an idea get them out come yeah
meow meow oh and be sure to take the dog
with the pot on his head and the broom
up his ass I I don't think he's well so
as the others are turned to evil cooler
and the cat's escape to find big Paul
now what are they gonna do let's hide
why do you keep hiding you have a dog
the size of a t-rex this movie should be
over in like two seconds those guys make
me mad so they break into the museum as
McNasty finally puts the bone back
together
and nothing happens he just sort of
declares himself gay
um bad news guy Britain has a parliament
and America elects the president this
doesn't really mean anything I mean are
you really expecting just to walk up to
the White House and be like looked me in
at what I am your new king
oh no you're not we got a president of
the boom the boom so through yet another
cliche chasing we see the bone slip back
and forth between everybody's hands
a cooler and big paw get trapped as they
try to figure out how the turn to evil
dogs back to good my darlings
that's it saying I love you changes them
back to normal
well that's a weird design flaw McNasty
when making his mean machine actually
factored in that the only way to reverse
it is saying I love you
how come love always seems to be the
atom bomb in these movies it always
seems to be the answer drat I've been
fooled by the power of love so they rush
after McNasty to finally put everything
right what about the cocks we'll lose
them too
nothing can stop me now that is except
for a small dog taking the wheel for me
a bigger dog grabbing on to the back a
few sloppy turns and a confusing ride
that leads me back to the museum where
the police are waiting don't let it
catch me I don't want to be reversed I
don't want to be a good guy
that takes care of them yeah but what
about the skull bone so they find the
bone McNasty is now a Mick goody and the
pound puppies have their adopting
bizarre oh and I guess whopper finishes
his story I see you brought some new
friends to meet me I'm sorry we believe
you're go opera
oh that's all right no harm done the
important thing is that with big paul
guarding the bone will never lose puppy
power again and thus puppy power stayed
forever remember kids you can talk to
your dogs if for some reason it doesn't
work there's something wrong with you
you should be ashamed of yourself and
feel totally awful that you're unable to
enjoy your dog sorry we don't know what
the fuck's wrong with you
maybe you're just an idiot what world
created this aside from just making no
sense at all the animations choppy the
characters are forgettable the songs are
crap it's just a stupid stupid stupid
movie with virtually nothing redeemable
about it whatsoever so remember the next
time you see a cute could be noodle
puppy in do PO not if I end up with more
bullshit like this I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it's um you don't have
to
ah
at the Bell
that's up to
I love you